hi leute ich es wieder eure mal wanne
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge
seine willst
im controlling nichts sagt das ist das
was so kim kardashian und keine jenna so
ins leben gerufen haben bzw bekannt
gemacht haben dass man sich das gesicht
mit schatten und hellen flächen
schlanker macht die wangenknochen
schöner rausgucken lässt und am anfang
war es so ein ding was nur so die
beauties glaube ich gemacht haben und
mittlerweile hat das so durchgesetzt es
ist wirklich jeden den ich kenne der sie
schminkt macht jetzt auch controlling
und ich selbst auch manchmal natürlich
gibt es die leute die damit übertreiben
aber darum soll es also gar nicht gehen
sondern ich habe mich gefragt was ist
wenn man dieses konto in der kelterung
macht da wo man hell machen soll dunkel
machen und darum mann eine dunkle macht
hält und dieses experiment passt super
zu bannewitz wissen deshalb lasst uns
los damit ich muss zu anfang sagen ich
bin kein profi ich habe so eine schatten
palette wo hell und dunkel drin sind und
ich habe irgendwann angefangen die zu
benutzen und seitdem ich nicht weiter
darum gekümmert und ich habe so ein
klein wenig fangen jetzt einfach mal bei
den banken an
das muss er das gesicht komplett
verändern controlling schon mit der so
vielen so ein knackiges gesicht was sie
eigentlich in wirklichkeit gar nicht
haben
ok dann auch hier es ist eigentlich
quatsch dass wir frauen dann tun wir
wissen selbst aber mit uns gern nicht
alle natürlich nicht alle jeder mensch
ist anders
viele die ich kenne die uns gern man
muss ja sagen make up gehört er schon
immer zu unserer kultur gab eigentlich
keine zeit doch mithalten sich nicht
durch noch darum selbst sich die könige
und die ganze ich auch schon geschminkt
nur halt nicht mit
mit schminke gespielt hat so jetzt kommt
bis dunkle vergesst nicht mädels das
dunkle immer auch die bank damit sie
schön rein gedrückt werden
as rom immer schön verblenden ich glaube
es wird einfach aus dem dreck gespielt
hätte
hierauf zu machen und ist immer noch
nicht so wirkungsvoll davon experiment
auch mal scheitern
ich sehe einfach mitbringen weil wir
dort meine gesicht form durch ändert
oder so zeigt euch das mal im tageslicht
so mädels das ist jetzt mein fertiges
ergebnis ich hoffe euch hat das video
gefallen macht das nicht nahe sie total
bescheuert aus ein experiment das
scheitern oder ja so dann habt ihr es
jetzt versucht es nicht das nicht lustig
und ihr seht außer bier direkt in der
fremde
bis zum nächsten video